the collaboration we didn't know we
needed on a Monday Shaquille joining
Adam Levine on stage meet maroon 6.
everybody Welcome to Entertainment
Tonight We had so much fun in Las Vegas
for Shaq's annual fundraiser E.T was
exclusively backstage where Adam made
his first public appearance with white
fiati Prince Lou since his alleged
cheating scandal
[Music]
Adam performed seven songs during his
40-minute set
goes a lot of things
biati was there to support Adam only ET
has this exclusive footage of the two
arriving walking arm in arm and this
moment after biati who's expecting their
third child holds her baby bum
[Music]
a source tells ET that Adam Levine and
Maroon 5 were given the option to bow
out of the fundraiser in the wake of the
Scandal but the ban insisted on
performing and raising money for the
kids the gala was sponsored by Shack's
Foundation which raised more than 3.1
million dollars for the boys and girls
club and schools throughout Las Vegas
and Atlanta people forget he sat
Courtside for your whole Lakers tenure
he did he helped me raise a lot of money
if his name wasn't on the flyer I'm
guarantee you know we wouldn't have that
3.1 so we want to wish him well he has a
lot of work to do at the crib he knows
what he has to do and I wish he went
fairly well while Shaq gave his support
Adam was skewered on SNL let's meet our
first contestant Adam Levine
guest host Miles Teller helped spoof the
singer's texting scandal with a skit
called send something normal if you send
a normal DM you win 100 million dollars
gonna kick things off with a whole holy
moly
[Music]
back to the All-Stars it's Shaq's
fundraiser heard dropped this bombshell
about host Joel McHale do you know that
this
had this career when I was 10 years old
so we bought Maury he played a clip of
me on his show and from there I signed a
record deal and I became her so thank
you thank you very much in your face
Ryan Seacrest
country star maren Morris posted this
wild pick showing her height difference
with Shaq she's five foot one he's seven
foot one my co-host Michelle Turner
sings your songs every single day
[Applause]
oh well thank you Michelle and I'm sorry
to you you have to hear it all the time
no no I love it I love it I just want
you she thinks she's you she thinks she
can sing like you I bet you can
foreign